joséphine bacon coup et barèges palin le
matin j'étais très ému par le film
je m'appelle humain de kim ho bong sawan
c'est l'histoire de votre vie de vos 15
ans pensionnaire mais aussi de votre
histoire de résilience votre arrivée à
montréal où vous êtes presque retrouvé à
la rue pour enfin devenir une grande
poétesse innu vous avez déjà dit que
l'écriture est arrivée par un accident
comment ça s'est passé d'accident est
arrivé j'ai une amie que j'aime beaucoup
et qui poète s'est elle écrit de la
poésie depuis qu'elle est auto jones et
une bretonne
elle s'appelle laure morali un jour du
puits d innover et coin type de manga
l'ont adopté parce qu'elle n'arrêtait
pas de faire des allers-retours quand
elle était toute jeune
depuis la cueillette qui ont fini par
l'adopter elle est même allée dans le
lendemain avec un vieux chasseur et ses
filles et puis un jour elle a fait un
rêve elle arrive son rêve lui disait tu
es de jumeler des écrivains poètes
québécois avec les premières nations
puis ça a donné entre temps parlons nous
on se trouve chez votre histoire mémoire
d'encrier qui a vraiment changé votre
vie en 2009 avec un premier recueil
bâton un message et vous avez écrit ceci
dans ce recueil toi qui m'as fait
gardienne de la langue
toi qui m'a chargé de poursuivre ta
parole
je sais que tu me vois qui vous a chargé
d'être une des gardiennes de la langue
inoue pourquoi vous avez accepté cette
mission là un jour il ya un vieux qui
m'a dit tu es et tu dis aujourd'hui je
te raconte mon savoir il m'a dit un jour
ce sera ton tour
et je pense que je le fais je le fais
quand même je le fais ce qui m'a demandé
de faire mais avec de la poésie c'est
que j'écris c'est eux mais poète les
anciens c'était des poètes la façon
qu'ils te raconter des des récits
anciens ou les art hogan fondateur
cétacés leur poésie qui te donne alors
que c'est à dire des fois ya eu un seul
mot c'est pour enfants seraient par
exemple deviendrait une grande grande
foi nous aurions besoin que de sol d'un
seul mot mais qui te traduit tellement
de belles choses que tu es un mou était
je le vois apparaître
tu le vois ces pépites souvent ce que tu
vois et hommes est inverse que vous
portez du violet en hommage à georges et
chaque rame à joyce et cette manne est
quelqu'un qu'est ce que ça vous dit
comment vous avez réagi qu'est-ce que
vous ça vous à propos du racisme occupé
mais tu vois quelqu'un je les regardais
partir en direct
tc sur les réseaux là je me disais c'est
pas possible
et quand tu la regardes partir t elle
s'en va avec sa langue ses penchants
séquelles pas qu'il entend parler en
attikameks tg piqûre ça ma tête j'avais
le coeur gros gros gros des charges et
de larmes plein plein plein plein de
larmes et puis je me disais on peut pas
on peut pas
laissez quelqu'un autant que ça c'est
dans ce manque de respect mais jeudi
elle est partie en gagnant un combat tu
vois aujourd'hui la grâce à elle
grâce à elle ce qui est des gens sont
ont pris conscience que ya du racisme
et puis à du racisme systémique
tu vas ci vers des lumières tel un
papillon qui brûle ses ailes les mots
ont parfois l'effet de réveil
alors je construis d'offenbach ans avec
votre poésie parce que vous permettez
que je vous lise une de vos plus belles
phrases selon moi un jeu peut la lire
notre club libyen
je me suis faite belle pour qu'on
remarque la moelle de maisons survivante
d'un récit qu'on ne raconte pas
joséphine bacon jeunesse comme thème
était je me suis fait d'elle pour qu'on
remarque la moelle de mézos survivante
d'un récit qu'on ne raconte pas